bonsoir a tous moi mon truc c'est la
rhétorique et j'aimerais vous montrer
qu'il faut se méfier des proverbes
exemple n'y a pas de fumée sans feu
peut-être mais il ya des chats sans
poils des doudoune sans manches
il y a des steaks sans viande et il ya
également des rumeurs sans fondement en
rhétorique
c'est ce qu'on appelle une métaphore
biaisé et c'est comme ça qu'on donne du
crédit à des préjugés ou des accusations
injustifiées
autre exemple rapidement qui vole un
oeuf vole un boeuf et là on va pouvoir
tous faire l'expérience ensemble
je suis sûr qu'on est un certain nombre
ici avoir déjà volé dans notre vie un
petit truc n'est ce pas genre un stylo
ou un briquet mais combien parmi nous
avons déjà volé un gros truc genre un
boeuf
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle un argument de
la pente glissante et c'est avec ce
genre de raisonnement que notre ministre
de l'intérieur en vient à nous dire
attention si vous consommez du cannabis
vous finirez cambrioleurs pour payer
votre dose peut être ou pas bref ne vous
laissez pas manipuler par les proverbes
il n'y a rien de moins évident que le
bon sens
[Applaudissements]